[Musique]
premier pays européen à avoir commandé
la hongrie a reçu hier dans ce camion
les quarante mille premières doses du
vaccin russe spoutnik premier pays à
recevoir le vaccin russe une provocation
du dirigeant viktor orban
alors que l'udc n'a pas encore homologué
le produit il n'y a pas de frontières
géopolitiques et un vaccin
il est bon on le prend et on pique alors
évidemment vous fait la transition
efficace à 91% selon la revue médicale
the lancet t'ont fait pas de politique
avec le vaccin
on a des critères uniquement sanitaires
et lexie de vaccins disponibles pour
console bien nous sommes tout à fait
ouverts mais il ya des procédures
nous sommes relativement plutôt confiant
sur la capacité à proposer aux français
qui souhaitent être vaccinés d'ici la
fin de l'été une vaccination
j'ai parlé au président russe à ce sujet
d'où les vaccins sont les bienvenus dans
lieu mais seuls ceux pour lesquels l'
agence européenne aura fourni les
données nécessaires seront approuvés
j'vous de nick est bien toléré il peut
se garder au frais dans un frigo il
n'est pas très cher moins de huit euros
la dose environ et il est possible qu'il
marche avec une seule dose des essais
sont en cours mais il reste un certain
nombre d'inconnues l'effet sur la
contagiosité la durée de l'immunité
les français ont fait mentir les
sceptiques les cyniques les narquois
parfois et ont montré leur détermination
à affronter ensemble le virus une fois
de plus la situation est entre nos mains
le confinement n'est pas une fatalité ce
sont nos efforts collectifs qui nous
permettront de l'éviter il n'y a aucune
évidence actuellement que les mesures
contraignantes étaient et joué le
moindre rôle dans le contrôle de
l'épidémie
pendant et compris la france que versus
la suède va faire corée du sud la suisse
l'angleterre
ça c'est sûr
si j'étais à la place d'emmanuel macron
justement je ne ferai pas une politique
de court terme à la petite semaine ou à
la petite soirée intervenants comme ça
pour se faire plaisir et pour dire
n'importe quoi comme il ya souvent dit
cette image qui nous arrive à l'instant
de chine devone très précisément les
experts de l oms sont arrivés ce matin à
l'institut de virologie de la ville tout
cela se passe dans le cadre de leur
enquête sur l'origine du coup aux
navires us
il
là
bien le trafic aérien a chuté de 75% aux
états unis et à force de ne pas
pratiquer leur métier certains en
auraient oublié quelques bons réflexes
c'est le la times un qui raconte par
exemple ce pilote qui oublient d'activer
le frein à main à une fois que l'avion a
atterri et kylie kylie gars est un autre
qui a oublié d'enclencher le système de
dégivrage des capteurs d'altitude ou
encore un pilote qui a dû s'y reprendre
à trois fois pour réussir à poser un jet
privé
une fusée spécifique s'est écrasé à
l'atterrissage s'est produit lors d'un
vol d'essai sur la côte du texas le vol
s'est bien passé vous connaissez le
principe des fusées aspect 6l d'école
elles ont une capacité bien en principe
de revenir se poser ce n'a pas été le
cas hier
en plus du manque de pratique les
pilotes seraient victimes du poids des
avions la plupart des vols sont quasi
vides ce qui modifie certaines
manoeuvres notamment l'atterrissage
résultat les autorise les autorités
américaines aériennes vont demander à
tous les pilotes de refaire des petits
stages de simulateur avant de reprendre
les vols en vrai dans les semaines qui
suivent hype
[Musique]
je le sais
sow